[Musique]
c'est à la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion que s'est jouée la pièce
ça a dit ma chance
une histoire une rencontre entre saadi a
remis à jeunes femmes malgaches et
cécile fontaine une artiste réunionnaise
tout en chansons saadi raconte son
histoire sa vie à madagascar jusqu'à son
voyage en russie où elle va poursuivre
ses études au plus point sur une
rencontre de ne pas hésiter d'aller vers
les gens parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que
les personnes possède quoi là et vous si
votre histoire que vous exerciez
et selon les soirs que je dois fois
assez saine et je joue une
représentation qui concrétise six mois
de résidence patrimoine et création à la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion pour l'artiste cécile fontaine
j'étais aussi dans ma vie en train de
d'explorer aussi loti chansons pour
exprimer un certain nombre de d'émotion
j'ai voulu aussi intégrer la musique est
intègre et damien mandrin avec rieux je
faisais déjà un travail poussé autour de
l'interprétation
c'est en fait ce qu'on recherche
à travers cette réelle cette résidence
d'artistes qu'on met en place c'est de
faire la passerelle avec les publics
entre notre site nos sites patrimoniaux
et la création et au milieu de tout ça
il ya nos artistes réunionnais qui crée
l'alchimie et cette alchimie elle est
parfaitement réussie et on l'a vu
aujourd'hui à travers ce rendu les
agents de la bibliothèque ont participé
à cette création originale en
présentation les femmes occupent
pleinement leur place dans la
scénographie
comme c'est un rêve qui se concrétise
j'aurais jamais pensé à presque 60 ans
pouvoir jouer dans un groupe comme ça
c'était fabuleux et chanter avec vos
collègues de travail sur un spectacle ça
fait quoi là bas ça c'est pareil ça veut
dire que
on se retrouve on apprend à se connaître
et c'est merveilleux
les deux représentations de saâdi ma
chance ont affiché complet le public est
venu nombreux découvrir ce subtil
mélange entre théâtre et chansons
[Musique]